Here is the simplest sales letter
structure in the world, okay? It is
called the four P framework. And what it
stands for is promise, picture, proof,
push. Okay, anytime you're writing a
sales landing page on a website, direct
mail, anything like that, you can break
it out into these four categories. And
it's broken out like this. You start
with the promise. Let's say you're in
the weight loss niche, and you say, "I
will help you lose 10 lb in 10 days
without giving up carbs." Great
headline, right? Boom, so that's your
big promise. You have to hit the
headline with the promise. Whether
you're running ads or emails or wherever
you're sending the traffic from, always
start with the promise. Then down here,
picture. This is your story. This is
where you come out and say, "Hey, my
name's Alan, and 10 years ago I was 60
lb overweight, sitting at my desk job,
cracking my back, and I had no plan to
lose that weight." So you tell the
story, you paint the picture, and then
you transport your reader emotionally of
what it looks like for them to be in
your shoes and actually lose that
weight. This is where you start telling
the mechanism behind the promise. Like,
why is my promise actually real, okay?
What do I do differently than everyone
else? So you paint the picture of them
emotionally, you paint the picture of
what you do differently, and you paint
the picture of your unique mechanism
that delivers this promise. And then
from there, you go to the proof.
And you start showing things like
testimonials, video testimonials, text
testimonials. You start showing things
like screenshots of results, all that
stuff. You got to litter with proof.
Especially the bigger the promise, the
bigger the proof, okay? You have to have
both of these aligned. If you have a
huge promise, but little proof, doesn't
work. If you have a small promise, but a
ton of proof, works sometimes because
proof outweighs the promise, but these
have to be aligned. And then from there,
once you have a butt ton of proof, you
go down to the push, and you and you
just make the offer. Make the offer, add
a great guarantee to it, and then and
then just make them click and buy. Make
sure you hold their hand. Click this,
buy now, make any bonuses you want,
anything like that. But, this structure
right here is absolutely going to slap
for you. I hope you crush it. And if you
missed it,